[Musique]
maintenant pourquoi on est là les
zombies comme toujours se rappeler d'où
ils sont là l'an tamoul
je préfère ça
prochain arrêt les angolais escaut sur
et musée la mayer
qu'est ce que c'est
il ya peut-être quelque chose que j'aime
un hommage à karl inouïe
n'ayez pas peur il se souvient comment
où jouent à chat et bien c'est trop de
personnes la base de mon dieu
[Musique]
on va tous quoi est ce qu'on va tous
crever mademoiselle caroline non ça fait
partie du jeu les zombies ne sont pas
réels mon pull qu'ils sont par les
blancs des mains travail consiste à vous
protéger
tu as la loi
[Musique]
ce type de comportement est inacceptable
que cinq ans et si vous n'arrivez pas à
parler correctement un enfant de 5 ans
je vais devoir vous demander de
descendre du tracteur et d'aller nous
attendre dans l'auto de sang